[Musik]
das sind hammer spritpreise ein liter
diesel unter einem euro hier in idar
oberstein einer stadt in rheinland pfalz
sogar der rekordpreis 91,9 cent
zwischendurch fiel der ölpreis sogar ins
negative
heißt wer öl fördert musste draufzahlen
um es loszuwerden warum der preis so
gesunken ist wenn corona steht die
wirtschaft still
keiner braucht öl zu viel angebot senkt
den preis
und wie gehen tankwarte damit um wir
haben uns den deutschen tankstellen mal
umgehört
wir sind die günstigsten mit die
günstigsten in deutschland eine
spritpreisen deswegen kommen die kunden
ja auch über radio teheran der
hauptgrund ist für uns verdienst mäßig
dass die kunden hier was kaufen was
essen was trinken was lesen am benzin
für die man am ehesten viel kundschaft
ein großer betrieb hot rods meisten
schlecht die leute tanken mehr
wendigkeit heruntergehen
aber die trinken auch viel mehr wer
pakete kommen natürlich auch mehr weil
fünf shops vor uns oder die umgebung
und was sagen die kunden hervorragend
nur die preise wissen festgeschrieben
wir haben dass man beim reisen sicher
billigen preise hat gespielt sofort nach
dresden formen an den tankstellen neues
benzin so billig ist und das muss man
nutzen
und ich finde das ganz klassen mit den
preisen 92,9 für den liter diesel was
die weltwirtschaft liegt zwar am boden
aber wir profitieren davon